the estoque shins are going on and we
are a constructive dialogue we lost with
all the authorities especially also in
the United States so we are looking
forward to have result as soon as
possible and there's this idea that
you'll come up with a plan by March the
24th are you confident confident that
you can conclude or come up with some
kind of plan that would be acceptable to
us authorities in a month's time as I
mentioned before the discussions are
going on and the constructive dialogue
is makes some progress so we will see
what happened to rings in the next weeks
and months where are you going to find
the money to pay for this scandal you've
already said that some of the money that
you set aside won't be enough you've
talked about the need to reduce some of
the models that VW produces cost-cutting
efficiencies where you can find all the
money it's an interesting question but
you can suppose that folks one is is a
company which is able to handle the
money and one of the most important
things will be to set priorities to the
things for the future kind of product
program in kind of autonomous driving
and kind of together ization or
immobility so we will do that and that
will be a progressive
issue so the key is to scrutinize your
investment plans so of course you should
and things like dividend getting rid of
some of your brand's no it's not not
attention to get rid of some friends we
are 12 very successful comp brands in
the in the groups and and we intend to
stay with it when analyst like UBS talk
about this costing more than 40 billion
dollars before it's all over speculation
do you agree that it could cost as much
no I cannot agree because we have to
wait on to the authorities and the
result